hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
spider-man homecoming continuing to
shoot the movie but just dropped a big
Avengers Easter Egg so this is going to
be a breakdown so the big news is that
spider-man is gonna take a little bit of
a field trip to the Avengers
headquarters the new avengers
headquarters Tom Holland was seen here
at the Porsche headquarters in Atlanta
which is near where they're filming the
movie like the actual studio where
they're filming the movie in the
building itself doubles as the new
avengers headquarters in the newer
marvel movies ever since the end of
Avengers age of Ultron so what initially
seemed like you know not up not a big
deal just like oh Tom Hall and maybe
he's going to pour ships headquarters to
test drive some cars just have some fun
with his friends nope there were a ton
of filming trucks reported near the
facility when he was there when this
picture was taken
so either spider-man is gonna go there
by himself or he's gonna go there with
his friends but if you guys haven't read
the comics in a long time or you didn't
read the original Civil War spider-man
was living inside the Avengers tower
with Mary Jane and Aunt May
now obviously the movies are very
different from the comics they did a
very different thing during civil war
but it makes sense that Tony Stark's
spending most of his time at the
Avengers facility that's where all of
his toys are his base of operations so
if he's gonna give spider-man some help
or some upgrades it makes sense that
they would do something at the Avengers
facility now part of it also might be
just showing spider-man what's waiting
for him if he stays on the path great
power great responsibility you could
almost say he's already an unofficial
Avenger Tony Stark invited him to be on
the team he's really more of a contract
player because he really only came on
for that brief fight in Germany but he
got the top-down redesign suit from Tony
Stark so he's already wearing his stark
tech suit but when you think of the
geography of New York State this is
really like an upstate New York so it's
kind of impractical for him to go live
there so you know I don't think they're
gonna be doing any of that stuff from
the comics anytime soon be either write
all the fanfiction you want I know we've
all been wondering about iron spider
stuff too like clearly there is a lot of
stuff that that Iron Man designed
spider-man suit can do that we haven't
seen yet just like a lot of hidden
things that they'll probably discover
through the course of the movie but I
feel like if they really want to go big
they'll do this from the comics where
Iron Man
shows Peter Parker his armory like if
you look way in the back there there's
even a bender robot from Futurama it's
ridiculous you can see how the Avengers
facility is really big we haven't seen
all of it we've really only seen like
the hangar we've seen the outside like
we see him walking down some hallways we
have the meeting room there's just a lot
of hidden treasure that we haven't got a
peek yet and I think Iron Man's armoury
from the comics would be like a really
big cool thing that they could put in
just like a brief tease of all the suits
of armor that he has on tab and I don't
think they're gonna do it but if they
really wanted to tease some toys they
would let Peter Parker climb into one of
his armor suits you know just to play
around just for fun like if this is
gonna be a John Hughes style spider-man
movie then think about Ferris Bueller's
Day Off in Cameron's dad's classic
Ferrari what kind of red Ferrari would
Tony Stark have well he's a billionaire
and a car geek so he probably actually
owns that classic car like it's in a
hangar somewhere but really his Iron Man
armor is the Ferrari so it'll be
hilarious at some point in the movie if
he destroys one of Iron Man suits of
armor like oops up you know just got
just gonna put this in the closet hope
that nobody notices it the cool thing in
the comics though is that because Tony
Stark's new AI Friday
remember Jarvis is vision now so Friday
is the new voice inside his head
she has like this connection to all of
stark technology so if someone actually
uses or activates one of his armors
anywhere in the world he immediately
knows about it like mr. Starks someone
is using your technology even if it's
been integrated and repurposed by
villains so if spider-man or one of his
friends tried to play with one of Tony
Stark's armors he would know instantly
but even if they don't go for that I'm
expecting a bunch of John Hughes movie
Easter eggs like they'll probably borrow
a couple lines of dialogue maybe a
couple of the jokes the weird thing
about parents in those movies though is
that they're kind of like these passive
blobs that just kind of exist in the
background like they're not really
active in the children's lives so like
Ferris Bueller's Day Off you have
Cameron's dad who would be kind of like
the Norman Osborn like he's this
terrible person that you never really
see on screen but Cameron like Harry
Osborne comes from money and lives in
constant fear of his dad just losing his
so it's going to be a little
while before we see that first trailer I
mean there's a rumor that it's gonna
come in the next two weeks or so so just
keep your eyes peeled but I'll be
curious to see what they show up like
it'll probably be a version of the
comic-con trailer so it'll be like a
funny remix usually the first teaser
that they show off doesn't give you too
much idea of the story it just shows you
some of the fun beats of the movie just
to get you hyped up then like the first
real big trailer after that is more of
like a story trailer where it's like oh
this is where spider-man is these are
what some of the other characters are
doing this is some of the conflict of
the movie so really wanted to a couple
days ago I did an Iron Man 4 hype video
if you didn't see it I talked about Jon
Favreau I mentioned that he's actually
reprising the role of happy Hogan but it
also seems like he's going to appear in
Avengers infinity war so where Iron Man
goes happy Hogan will follow in the hope
is is that long term Jon Favreau will
come back to actually direct a new Iron
Man movie or at least a new Marvel movie
if it's not gonna be an Iron Man movie
it's just that right now he's actually
blowing it up pretty bit he's actually
doing really well so from a scheduling
standpoint with the films that they have
available that they haven't scheduled
directors for it's just not gonna work
out so I'm not expecting Jon Favreau to
direct a new Marvel movie till at least
phase four so that's a ways off but if
you guys are wondering why they're using
a porch facility to double as an
Avengers building you know one it's just
in proximity to where they normally film
so it's close by and it looks kind of
cool so I think that's the biggest
reason but to both Porsche and Audi are
owned by the same company by the
Volkswagen Group so like that big black
panther Winter Soldier chasing during
Civil War when they're right you know
they're chasing each other through that
tunnel all of those cars are new audi z'
like the brand new Audi models so it's
kind of an extended outtie ad and audi
paid Marvel millions of dollars to be
featured so that's why you see like the
Audi logos very clearly it's like a very
sly way to do an ad it's called product
placement it's very common in movies but
Porsche from a corporate standpoint is
just like Audi is cousin like they're
related because they are both owned by
the same company so it's probably really
easy and cheap for Marvel to film at
this facility so it just makes a lot of
sense from a practical and from a
financial standpoint so that is why the
New Avengers facility looks mysteriously
like the Porsche headquarters but
giveaway time congratulation
- this week's Captain America giveaway
winner lizard eight one three you win a
gift certificate for the Captain America
blu-ray just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details there is a
new round that starts now all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video I'll keep doing
it all the way through the agents of
shield premiere there is a new Ghost
Rider promo but there's not really any
new footage in it so I wasn't gonna do a
video for it but agents of shield
premieres on Tuesday next week if you
guys didn't know it's totally back it's
like the first big Marvel show this
dropping then the week after that in
about two weeks from now Luke Cage is
dropping so I'll remind everyone about
the schedule when I post new Marvel
videos but in related news if you guys
remember when Stephen Amell fought
Stardust on SummerSlam they just dropped
a new arrow season 5 trailer Cody Rhodes
who is Stardust or was Stardust is guest
starring he appears in the trailer
giving it to Stephen Amell big time so
payback is a I'll be posting a
video for that later tonight so get hype
it looks like he is jacked up on
mirakuru it's gonna be awesome watching
him thrash Oliver while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
watch that Ghost Rider trailer again and
you can click here to learn all about
killer frost this season on the flash
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight